what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder i'm your host
warren thompson and we are back with
some spider-man news spider-man no way
home came out in december and it blew
our minds and it blew away some box
office records and it did this kind of
still in a pandemic but that is the
power of spider-man especially three
spider-men in one film spider-man is one
of my personal favorite characters and
now spider-man knowing home is one of
the best marvel movies of all time in my
opinion and of course the great news is
it looks like sony and marvel studios
are not stopping we have two really
awesome pieces of news today to go over
that i know fans are going to be really
really excited about and if you were
worried or still are worried about sony
spider-man universe which i kind of am
perhaps this video will put you a little
bit more at ease and help you feel a
little bit better about the future of
sony spider-verse and spider-man in the
marvel cinematic universe so let's dive
into the news and if you love spider-man
and marvel be sure to subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
videos so like i said we have two brand
new reports today that are really great
so let's start off with the one that's
gonna give fans hope about the future of
spider-man and the sony universe and
that is that kevin feige is going to be
working a lot closer with sony for their
own projects so not just spider-man in
the mcu projects but their other sony
picture universe of marvel characters
whatever you want to call it now
whatever they're calling it now kevin
feige is going to be working closer with
sony kind of as a consultant with them
now this is fantastic news because a lot
of people were really worried about the
future of sony spider-verse especially
after morbius yes it was an okay movie
it wasn't as terrible as everybody said
it was and yeah now it's a really big
meme but it did not perform well at the
box office but here's the really cool
thing amy pascal and kevin feige have
been working together for a very long
time in fact their relationship is the
only reason that spider-man was actually
allowed to come into the mcu in fact
spider-man and the mcu all started
because amy pascal and sony wanted to
consult with kevin feige for the third
amazing spider-man film kevin feige went
over to meet with amy pascal in which he
said hey it's not gonna work you need to
let marvel studios do it you need to
scrap your plans for the amazing
spider-man 3 and spider-man needs to
come into the mcu ultimately sony ended
up agreeing and that's how we got tom
holland spider-man appearing in the mcu
in captain america civil war which was
fantastic it was an amazing moment in
the mcu but the point of the story is
sony wanted to consult with kevin feige
about their spider-man and their
spider-man universe before and now it's
happening again and if you take a look
at the success of the homecoming series
especially no way home it makes sense
kevin feige did an amazing job and of
course everybody else involved did an
amazing job as well but to make a long
story short kevin feige is now going to
be working closer with sony for their
spider-man properties not just
spider-man itself but all of the stuff
that they have coming up craven the
hunter madame webb and venom 3 which is
supposed to be a venom vs spider-man
film which everybody is really excited
for except we don't know which
spider-man is going to be in the movie
but this question actually brings us to
our newest report and that is and the
amazing spider-man fans will be really
excited that andrew garfield has signed
a multi-movie deal one of these movies
possibly being avengers secret wars
which is absolutely insane to hear and
awesome secret wars has been rumored to
be the next big avengers project for a
while now there's so many things that
point towards this being the next big
thing and a lot of the insiders have
said that yes it is going to be the next
big crossover film and what's cool is
that a lot of them have said that it's
actually coming sooner rather than later
now this report is coming from a giant
freaking robot and they say exclusive
andrew garfield officially signs on for
future marvel movies in their report
they say andrew garfield isn't done with
marvel just yet after his instantly
classic team-up with tom holland and
toby mcguire versions of peter parker
and spider-man no way home garfield is
coming back for more our trusted and
proven source has confirmed the
oscar-nominated actor has signed the
dotted line to come back for more marvel
flicks now backing up a little bit to
right after spider-man know my home's
release when everybody finally knew for
themselves that andrew and toby were
indeed in spider-man no way home a bunch
of insiders came out including daniel
rbk and said that sony and marvel wanted
andrew garfield and toby maguire back to
do more projects now right away we
speculated that it was going to be more
andrew than toby considering toby
maguire's age and it looks like we were
right if one of them were going to come
back to play a major role in the mcu or
the sony spider-man universe it was
going to be andrew garfield and if this
report is true andrew garfield will be
in secret wars and possibly some other
projects now secret wars does seem to be
coming sooner rather than later and
marvel is definitely paving the way for
this build up especially with everything
that happened in doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness in doctor strange
2 they introduced us to the illuminati
and incursions incursion is basically
what happens when two universes collide
into each other causing the destruction
of one or both and this is what actually
happens in the comics the illuminati try
to protect the multiverse from
incursions however incursions happen and
universes collide ultimately this leads
up to the events of secret wars where
there is only one world left but there
are a bunch of different variants of the
same characters for example the person
in charge of this world battle world is
god emperor doom and he uses the thor
core as kind of his police and there are
many many different versions of thor in
the thor core and that's what secret
wars is a bunch of different variants of
the same characters and that's what
we're hoping for in the secret wars mcu
adaptation and based off of everything
we've seen and heard so far this is the
direction that marvel's going which
means eventually when we get to this
movie it'll be a movie where we do have
a bunch of different variants of the
same character all on screen together so
multiple different spider-men multiple
different captain america iron man the
cool thing is that anything is really
possible in this movie we could see
robert downey jr back as iron man of
course not as the same tony stark
because he died in our universe but from
a different universe we can see a bunch
of different x-men there a bunch of
wolverines together we can see our new
fantastic four with the older versions
of the fantastic four you get the
picture and if this new report ends up
being true it looks like andrew garfield
will be back as a different variant of
spider-man and the timing of this i have
to say is pretty coincidental it's been
announced that marvel studios is going
to be attending san diego comic-con this
year they're also going to be attending
d23 of course and kevin feige made it
clear that some announcements are coming
and we're actually going to start to see
how the mcu is going to be connected in
phase 4 5 and 6. and he pretty much
hinted that it's secret wars he said
that the hints are there we could see
the hints in the current mcu projects
and all of the hints like the illuminati
trying to protect the multiverse from
incursions point to secret wars so that
is extremely extremely exciting now with
the andrew garfield news it doesn't say
that he's just coming back for secret
wars they said that it's going to be a
multi-movie contract which means he
could be coming back as sort of the main
spider-man for the sony universe and
specifically what i'm personally
thinking is that he's going to be the
spider-man in venom 3. since marvel
teased us and didn't really take us all
the way with tom hardy's venom fighting
tom holland spider-man putting tom
hardy's venom in the mcu just to take
him out and leave a piece of the
symbiote behind basically confirmed that
tom holland's spider-man is going up
against a different symbiote and venom
that is not tom hardy so we're left with
a spider-man void who is going to be the
spider-man to go up against tom hardy's
venom and the sony universe i believe
this is going to be andrew garfield i
believe this before this news but now i
especially believe this especially if
you think about that line from
spider-man no way home where toby
mcguire is talking about fighting an
alien which was venom tom holland was
talking about fighting an alien which
was thanos and andrew garfield said i
want to fight an alien well it looks
like he might be getting that chance to
fight an alien in venom 3 going up
against tom hardy's venom which i really
really think that a lot of fans would
really love i know i personally would
but let me know your thoughts about this
in the comments down below and let me
know how excited you are for andrew
garfield to return to the mcu possibly
in secret wars leave your comments down
below don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
all things related to the mcu for live
updates you can follow me on instagram
and twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching woof